ukraine's presidential elections may
help solve one major problem here who is
in charge three but a new president will
face several serious challenges
including the country's contentious gas
dispute with Russia speaking simply it's
simple blackmail and Rico velov recently
took over Ukraine's state-owned gas
company NAFTA gas his firm gets almost
all its gas from Russian energy giant
Gazprom which has recently doubled its
prices to a level that cobble off and
Ukraine's political leaders say is
unreasonable what's it like having
conversations with them about price I'd
say is it it's not constructive and see
conversations we have they are not
bringing any results the politics of gas
to both these state controlled entities
the often aging storage facilities and
Ukraine's internal divisions are all
consequences of a shared Soviet past the
armed fighting may be taking place
hundreds of miles away in East but it's
here in the peaceful west of Ukraine
just a few miles from the border with
Hungary and Slovakia that an economic
and political dispute is really raging
it's focused on gas pipelines like these
that are so crucial to Europe's energy
needs gas from piped 112 billion cubic
meters of gas into Ukraine last year
around three-quarters continued on to
Europe with the remainder used
domestically for household heating and
industrial energy NAFTA gas may earn
billions each year for transiting
Gazprom's gas but it also pays billions
for those domestic gas needs and that's
where much higher prices will hurt NAFTA
gas says Dennis akwa a gas analyst at
dragon capital in Kiev most of the
company bills are in the united states
dollars while residential consumers pay
fixed tariffs and those tears are fixed
in greenness here's the problem the
Greve near ukraine's currency has fallen
around forty percent against the dollar
since the start of the year so when gas
from demands payment in dollars but
NAFTA gases itself paid in green here it
gets squeezed Russia's Prime Minister
Dmitry Medvedev says that's not Russia's
problem I think any creditor is entitled
to get their debt repaid therefore we
expect to receive the repayment
debt that is accumulated over the time
from Ukraine and the respective company
the debt currently stands at 3.5 billion
u.s. dollars and may rise by another 1.6
billion next week unless Ukraine can
persuade Russia to drop its prices the
same times yes its political weapon
sometimes it's very efficient leverage
that you can use on a consumer which is
highly dependent on large supply
ultimately the real issue says dragon
capital aqua is simple it's a
competition problem right now the
Russians are the only game in town and
Ukraine's new leadership will have no
choice but to deal with and buy from gas
prom